hello everyone welcome to part four of
our series on nlu nir
the screencast will be the second among
three of our videos on neural
information retrieval
just to recap this is the functional
view of neural ir that we left in the
previous screencast
our model will take a query and a
document and will then output a score
that will estimate the relevance of this
document to the query
we will sort the documents by decreasing
score
to get the top k results
let's begin
with a very effective paradigm for
building neural ir models
namely query document interaction
so given a query and a document will
tokenize them
then we'll embed the tokens of each into
a static vector representation
so these could be glove vectors for
example
or the initial
representations of birth
we'll then build what is called a query
document interaction matrix this is
typically nothing but
a matrix of cosine similarities between
each pair of word
um each pair of words across the query
and the document
now that we have this matrix we just
need to reduce it to a single score that
estimates the relevance of our document
to this query
to do this we'll just learn a bunch of
neural layers like convolution or linear
layers with pooling
until we end up with a single score for
this query document pair
many ir models out there fall in this
category especially ones that were
introduced between 2016 through 2018 or
2019.
with enough training data
query document interaction models can
achieve considerably better quality than
bag of words models like bm25
and they can actually do that at a
reasonable increase
moderate increase in computational cost
so as discussed in the previous
screencasts
these models are typically used um as
the last stage of a re-ranking pipeline
and in particular
in this
figure here they're used to re-rank the
top thousand passages retrieved by bm25
and this is done to make sure that their
latency is acceptable
while still improving the mrr
and the quality over bm25 retrieval
more recently in 2019 the ir community
discovered the power of birth for
ranking
functionally this is very similar to um
the paradigm that we just saw with query
document interactions
so here we'll we're going to feed both
the query and the document as one
sequence with two segments one segment
for the query and one segment for the
document as shown
we'll run this through all the layers of
birth
and we'll finally extract the class
token embedding from birth and reduce it
to a single score through a final linear
head on top of
birth as you can probably tell this is
nothing but a standard birth classifier
where we're going to take the scores
or the confidence that's the output of
the classifier and use it for ranking
our passages
and like any other task with bert we
should first fine-tune this birth model
with appropriate training data before we
use it for our task
we've discussed how to train neural ir
models in the previous screencast so
refer to that if you'd like
so this really simple model on top of
birth was the foundation to tremendous
progress in search over the past two
years
and in particular um
it's worth mentioning the first public
instance of this which was in january of
2019 on the ms marco passage ranking
task
here nogueira and cho
made a simple birth-based submission to
the leaderboard of ms marco
that demonstrated dramatic gains over
the previous state of the art submitted
just a few days prior
by october of 2019 almost exactly one
year after birth originally came out
google had publicly discussed their use
of birth in search
and being followed soon after
in november of the same year
but the story is actually a bit more
complicated
these very large gains in quality came
at a drastic increase in computational
cost
which dictates latency
and which is very important for user
experience in search tasks as we've
discussed before
so
over simple
query document interaction models like
duet or config nrm
noguera and chose birth models increased
mrr by over eight points but also
increase latency
to multiple seconds per qui
and so here it is natural for us to ask
ourselves the question
if we could achieve high mrr and low
latency at once
and it turns out that the answer is yes
but it will take a lot of progress to
get there
and we'll try to cover that in the rest
of the screencast in the next one so
let's get started with that
so to seek better trade-offs between
quality and latency which is our goal
let's think about why birth rankers are
so slow
our first observation here will be that
birth rankers are quite redundant in
their computations
if you think about what birth rankers do
um they need to compute a context
a contextualized representation of the
query for each document that we rank so
that's a thousand times for 1 000
documents
and they also must encode each document
for every single query that comes along
that needs a score for that document
of course we have the documents in our
collections in advance and we can do as
much pre-processing as we want on them
offline before we get any queries
so the question becomes can we somehow
pre-compute some form of document
representations in advance once and for
all using these powerful models that we
have like bert and store these
representations or cache them somewhere
so we can just use them quickly every
time we have a query to answer
this will be our guiding question for
the remainder of this and the next
screencasts
of course it is not actually obvious yet
at least if we can pre-compute such
representations in advance without much
loss in quality for all we know so far
there might be a lot of empirical value
in jointly representing queries and
documents at once
but we'll put this hypothesis to the
test
the first approach to tame the
computational latency of birth for ir is
learning term weights
the key observation here is that bag of
words models like bm25 decompose the
score of every document into a summation
of term document weights
and maybe we can do the same so
can we learn these term weights with
bert in particular
a simple way to do this would be to
tokenize the query and the document
feed birth
only the document and use a linear layer
to project each token
in the document into a single numeric
score
the idea here is that we can save these
document term weights to the inverted
index just like we did with bm25
in classical ir and quickly look up
these term weights when answering a
query
this makes sure we do not need to use
bert at all when answering
equity
as we just shifted all of our birth work
offline to the indexing stage
so this can be really great we now get
to use birth to learn much stronger term
weights than bm25
um
and deep city and doctorquity are two
major models under this efficient
paradigm
as the figure shows at the bottom
they indeed greatly outperform bm-25 and
mrr but actually they have comparable
latency because we're still using an
inverted index to do the retrieval
however
the downside is that our query is back
to being a bag of words and we lose any
deeper understanding of our queries
beyond that
so our central question remains whether
we can jointly achieve high mrr and low
computational cost and as we said before
the answer is yes
and to do this
we'll discuss in the next screencast two
very exciting paradigms of neural ir
models that get us close to the scope